TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm now
here with Kristen Johnson,
the lead product
manager on Fabric.
Kristen, how are you?
KRISTEN JOHNSON: Doing well.
We've had a great day
here in Amsterdam.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, it's
been really incredible.
Now you were in the
keynote this morning,
and you talked a little
bit about something
that I know you're
really passionate about,
and that's bringing Fabric
and Firebase together
for developers.
Can you tell us a little
bit about this project
and your passion for it?
KRISTEN JOHNSON: Sure,
so since we joined Google
earlier this year, we realized
that our missions are really
strongly aligned across
Firebase and Fabric.
So we thought the
best thing to do
was to work together
to bring the best
platform to developers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: One
of the other things
you talked about was Crashlytics
being in the Firebase console
and that enabling interaction
such as Crashlytics
plus functions.
Can tell me a bit
more about that?
KRISTEN JOHNSON:
Right, so we're really
excited about this
integration because you
can take Crash events and
trigger a cloud function.
So you can think about a
really powerful example,
like when you really care a
lot about [INAUDIBLE] flows
and something goes wrong
and you have a crash,
you want to make sure that that
gets to the people who can fix
that as fast as possible.
So we have it so you
could, for example, set it
up so it connects to Slack
or PagerDuty, the things
that you already use
in your workflow,
to make sure that you fix the
issue as soon as possible.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
All right, is
there anything else
that developers should
be looking out for?
KRISTEN JOHNSON: I
think you're going
to see more and more Fabric
plus Firebase integrations,
so we'll talk more about
that probably at Google IO.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome,
thank you so much.
KRISTEN JOHNSON: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for joining me here
at the Firebase Dev
Summit 2017 in Amsterdam.
For links to all the session
videos, look in the description
below.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]